Peter Krause breaks his silence on
losing the bachelor gig plus we're
making milkshakes with kelis only here
on the daily Denny hi friends and happy
national chocolate milkshake day to
celebrate I got a treat for you
pun intended who better to hook us up
with her favorite milkshake recipe than
kelis but first a bachelor exclusive
bachelor nation was up in arms when
Peter Krause was not named the next
Bachelor
it was believed that before ABC shocked
fans by going with re lighting Dec jr.
Peter was still a front-runner well he
is finally explaining what really
happened to our Lauren Zima and it may
surprise you for not a lot of fans were
blindsided by the fact that you are not
the bachelor were you blindsided I know
I wouldn't say so you know I have my
reasons for wanting to or not wanting to
do the show and I'm happy with things
right now I guess that's what you play
ultimately did you say no to being a
bachelor the conversations that we had
were never specific yes or no it was
more already ready and me saying I was
not I would never say it was a clear to
find answer it's just this is where rat
broke a with going different directions
at what point did you know this is not
for me
Oh instantly when I got off rachel
season I was devastated and it was a
hard breakup when we were just talking
about it myself in the producers it
wasn't something that I felt I was ready
for emotionally I was still needing more
time seeing the reaction on social media
it was hard to see that there's people
that were so avidly against me being it
I didn't know how things would go and I
didn't want to risk the happiness that
I've developed in my own life for that
larger risk at that time could you see
yourself being the bachelor in the
future is that door open if the offer
were to come up again in the future I
could see myself doing it seems like an
amazing opportunity it's not what I said
in my yearbook which was something I
dreamed of doing all
that one's always been fun to hear about
but at this stage of my life you know
I'm single I'm happy business is good
family is good I'm ready for the next
step again and if that's what route it
took I'd be okay with that so there you
have it folks
Peter's not completely ruling the show
out but I'm calling it right now our boy
is probably gonna find someone IRL
before the bachelor comes back around
for him so good luck to you Pete
all right you know another decision that
has the world divided at the moment JJ
Abrams has been tapped to get behind the
director's chair again for Star Wars
Episode nine replacing Colin Trevorrow
as director fans on Twitter are split on
whether JJ is the dark side or a new
hope for the sequel to help us decide
we've got our movie expert and Star Wars
Queen ash crossing with us how you
feeling I told you it's got people
divided by Twitter I glitch too this
morning I'm gonna work just a full-on
glitch what's your take on it
listen I know that my initial reactions
reaction was that JJ is a safe choice
but is he I mean he's made some bold
choices he essentially made the most
clever reboot to a franchise of all time
where you didn't even notice that it was
a reboot and at this point it doesn't
seem like Rian Johnson is rebooting
Empire Plus JJ Abrams is executive
producing episode 8 so he knows what's
going on he knows these characters he's
created these characters he is the right
person to bring this trilogy full circle
but what's interesting is I know that
Ron Howard of course is taking over for
Phil Lord and Chris Miller for the Han
Solo spin-off so clearly the Star Wars
Galaxies wants veteran filmmakers
especially with something as massive as
Episode nine Ameri and therein lies
another issue that I have a con
Lucasfilm has not made any diverse
choices in terms of directors I mean we
constantly throw out directors like Ava
Duvernay and patty Jenkins into the mix
but at this point
white dudes have directed Star Wars and
that's it and that needs to change
sooner rather than later but for episode
9 I am glad that it's JJ I think you're
right there but we do want to know what
you guys are thinking about JJ taking
over you know you can also chat with ash
about Twitter time Twitter not about
Twitter about Star Wars of course for
Ganesha all right and finally the moment
you've been waiting for it's been nearly
15 years since kelis
turned our favorite treat into an iconic
euphemism and
she's sharing her favorite milkshake
recipe and what she really thinks of the
song now it's not every day you could
say you're making a milkshake with kelis
[Music]
you were still jamming - that's not be a
part of something that I mean like girls
like kids come up to me all right but
it's like it still works it still has
such a you know the beat is strong and
it's fun it's I know a lot of fans out
there want to know are you working on
any new music you know I'm always
writing and I'm always kind of like I
mean yeah I stay in the scene you're
just sort of creating but I don't know
what happening yet but I'm just sort of
living I'm cooking that's right
making mochi we're gonna put those
recipes skills to the test what we made
today well obviously it's national
chocolate milkshake diet so I wanted to
do something decadent and really rich
and lush I decided to make my chocolate
milkshake now I'm interested not gay and
you're actually a spokesperson right yes
okay so here we've got we've got
chocolate ice cream so we're just gonna
add this in here isn't ever too much no
we've got our here so how much record
you actually put in this thing you know
I would say we're gonna measure it will
do like two depends on what time of day
it is not honestly that's so quick so
I've never heard of a milkshake with
ginger beer before that's some bubbles a
little flavor there yeah it just gives
it a nice kick this is some candied
ginger and then just a little bit here
this is cayenne so don't go crazy and
then you like it spicy huh I do I love
it I'm with you put some ice in there
just
and then you blend all right well you've
been doing all the work TV magic by the
way we got our milkshakes I can't wait
to get into this but first we gotta add
some whipped cream right yeah see you
got that man okay
this is the industrial one you guys are
no joke with this okay here we go wish
me luck
first boozy milkshake I cannot wait here
we go are you kidding me right whoa that
sounds like a little kick to ya but is
so good this is gonna bring all the boys
to the yard away oh I had to right
cheers thanks for this milk oh my god
all right first it's making milkshakes
with kelis necks lemonade's with Beyonce
a boy can dream all right I'm telling
you guys that milkshake was so freakin
good and lucky for you we have the full
recipe up over in the YouTube community
tab until then drink up
but responsibly of course and I'll see
you guys tomorrow ie